ce que vous faites c'est de
l'intimidation bonjour monsieur sa
démocratie franchement à
dispositon vous rappelle que vous n'avez
rien à faire ici vous êtes un marchand
de sommeil plus la cité se dégrade et
moins cher vous racheter les
appartements
vas-y deux fois hier calme bonjour là
bonjour on va tout rénover le bâti le
chauffage l'ascenseur avec un plan de
rénovation sur 31 - ils ont besoin qu'on
leur tende la main une main 63 millions
d'euros clément la question si on fait
quoi bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cap à tout moment là que celui de maire
vous avez peur de croo exactement
d'assumer un peu d'ambition vous avez
exactement le profil du gouvernement un
passeport une chieuse quelqu'un va vous
contacter pour caler un rendez vous
avec le premier ministre
propose d'être ministre président je
vais me faire broyer ça n'aiderait de
comprendre un peu comment ça fonctionne
dans ta tête finalement je te croyais
est différent des autres mais des prêtes
à vendre père et mère pour quelques
miettes de pouvoir
[Musique]
ça fait 12 ans que je la vois sur
bagarrer pour les bernardin comme si
l'avenir de l'humanité en dépendent et
je te demande juste de lui faire
confiance un peu quel point ça fait
vingt ans jean beaupré l'état trouvera
toujours une bonne raison pour ne rien
faire je les prends sur kylie minogue
vous faites comme vous voulez vous vous
démerdez je m'en fous de votre cuisine
on cherche des personnalités pas des
pirates de la politique je ne suis pas
là pour vous des combats se battre je
suis là vous voyez qu'on va gagner
on va laisser passer 63 millions sans
rien faire tahar est maintenant j'essaye
juste de comprendre de ce papier dépend
l'avenir d'une cité l'avenir de plus de
3000 personnes en détresse on abandonne
on n'en reste pas mois je suis pas
d'accord
donc je suis honnête mais je mens une
promesse non tenue c'est par nation
[Musique]